hey guys so I just got to the Intel
Extreme Masters event and I am so tired
the game Awards was yesterday so I flew
in from Vegas to San Jose this morning I
actually have not slept yet but first
we're gonna go have some fun we're gonna
go check out some really fun things with
Intel and watch some legal edge and they
keep meeting people to like just and I
know you played League I was like okay
2015 I I would like to start playing
that's what I'm going to dedicate some
time so if you guys like these League of
Legends tips in the comments below
it'd be much appreciated I just I just
oh my god there's so many video games
out separating sure up here is the best
seat in the house not only is there
coffee but you can be absolutely
everything
Samson was 10 years old the stopper
camping life was not
ESL stop running into extreme
it has existed for half of the players
lives our beginnings were at the time
when CRT monitors were still a thing
it has two HDMI ports you can run two
monitors documents and these guys over
here are actually playing on it right
now
Minnie and I've got your phone you put
it into the tab like not really
this mirror what's on yours oh hold on
they'll also charge your phones and not
only all right so I am finally back home
from San Jose I had so much fun at the
event it was awesome
I really actually enjoyed meeting so
many of you guys and was kind of crazy
cuz I was like well this is a league of
Legends event it's not Call of Duty so
I'm probably not gonna know anybody and
I met so many of you guys and you were
all so awesome and so nice definitely
don't be one of those people if you ever
see me out and about that you just take
a picture and then post it on Twitter
and say I just saw you I was too scared
to say hi don't ever be scared come say
hi I appreciate it and I like getting to
meet you guys so I am now shooting some
videos I'm waiting for Jenna to come
over and I'm about to open up my Star
Wars advent calendar to Luke from dad
okay maybe I'll open up the first day
just for you guys I'm gonna do this
right now
who watch is it is it okay just a sneak
peek you saw nothing here you saw
nothing
you saw nothing you will see it later in
the full video alright guys I hope
you're enjoying vlogmas happy vlogmas
day under day here
I'll see you later